there are a lot of mechanics that anthem
doesn't make abundantly clear
for instance combos are a damage-dealing
mechanic that's essential in combat but
the game only lightly touches on their
execution and importance and there are
several tidbits like this that are
likely to go right over your head to
help you transform into the best
freelancer you can be we've highlighted
several tips that will enhance your
abilities both in and out of combat
we've also included further insight and
clarification on ancillary aspects of
the game you might have questions about
so let's get on to it
when you examine special abilities
you'll notice that some are called
primers like the Rangers eyescreen aid
or interceptors venom spray while others
are labeled as detonators like Colossus
siege artillery or storms lightning
strike if an enemy has been hit by a
primer hitting them with a detonator
will cause them to detonate causing a
special damage effect to trigger this
sequence of damage dealing is what
anthem calls combos primers and
detonators can be identified by small
icons in the UI primers are designated
by a semi filled circle and detonators
are marked with a four pointed star each
javelin has a different effect that
activates upon successfully detonating a
combo Rangers critical target simply
inflicts the largest amount of damage to
detonated enemies Colossus explosion
causes all detonations to explode and
damage nearby enemies storms spread
makes all detonations explode and spread
an elemental effect to nearby enemies
and interceptors aura makes it so
detonating an enemy causes an elemental
effect to be imbued into the javelin
which can be inflicted onto nearby
enemies through proximity and melee
attacks as a final note javelins can
trigger combos with melee attacks as
well Colossus storm and interceptor have
detonator melee attacks while Ranger has
a primer melee attack
before you embark on a mission with your
javelin make sure you have both a primer
and a detonator in your loadout for
example you might want to choose an ice
elemental primer and then choose a fire
elemental detonator as your secondary
there aren't a lot of ways for your team
to communicate when they've set up a
combo so packing your own primers and
detonators can ensure you net that extra
damage as a group in addition having
both primer and detonator weapons in
your loadout allows you to access combos
during solo play
[Music]
this seems like a given but don't forget
to dodge with your javelins flight
capabilities you might be fooled into
thinking you're speedy enough to avoid
incoming attacks but when an enemy
starts using homing attacks as speedy
dodge will get you out of trouble way
more easily you can dodge up to three
times with one button press by holding
down dodge and a direction it's much
quicker than flying around the
battlefield to avoid set homing attacks
many players mistake the Colossus for a
tank and choose it early on but the real
tank is the Interceptor the interceptors
ultimate enables a period of
invulnerability that can be used for
attacking or simply buying time to
revive a downed team member if you're
looking to protect your team
the speedy maneuvers and abilities of
the Interceptor are a must if you're
switching over to a Colossus take note
that it uses shields differently
compared to other javelins in fact it
can't even perform a traditional dodge
instead using the Dodge button as the
Colossus raises a physical shield with
its own health meter which absorbs all
incoming damage and it can even be used
to melee or ram into enemies the
Colossus is shield is useful in a
variety of offensive and defensive
situations so don't hesitate to make use
of it to support your squad
Titans have several weak points that
shift through the battle their forearms
back and chest you'll notice each of
these areas will glow yellow and look
open when they're exposed these areas
will only open when the Titan is
attacking so it's usually a good idea to
have the team spread out anyone who
isn't the target of the attack
laying down damage as the targeted
teammate distracts the Titan make sure
to focus all your fire during these
moments and Titan fights should go a lot
more smoothly
[Music]
you probably know you can cool off
underwater or by flying through
waterfalls but you can also delay
overheating by flying close to shallow
water sources and by nose-diving
this is a handy way to extend your
flight time
[Music]
[Applause]
if you'd rather go at it alone you can
launch solo missions through the privacy
menu at mission launch this comes highly
recommended for players who prefer
experiencing the story as playing with
others opens up the possibility of
getting left behind and missing certain
sections due to the game's insistence on
teleporting you to your party if you
can't keep up
if you're playing with friends it's a
good idea to turn subtitles on just in
case someone is talking while you're in
a cutscene or trying to hear dialogue it
makes things much easier to follow
keeping you focused on the drama while
still being able to communicate with
friends
[Music]
in your time spent flying around the
world and exploring for Tarsus you
slowly discover more about anthems world
and characters however the game actually
has far more storytelling than it lets
on peruse your email for instance to
find detailed tidbits that further flesh
out the world while adding a welcoming
sense of realism to its inhabitants if
you're a fan of digging deep into lore
check your codex often especially after
interacting with objects and NPCs and
for Tarsus or discovering landmarks
during free play and that's all the tips
we've got for you but were there any
essential ones you know of that we
didn't highlight here let us know in the
comments below and be sure to check back
in the coming days for more Anthem
guides thanks for watching everybody
you
[Music]